france doit sortir avec succès de cette
crise quand je souhaitais du de la
région vente est en tout cas le quartier
général du retour à la vie normale et de
la relance c'est pour ça que je me bats
c'est parce que je me suis battu pendant
cette crise est ce pour ça je souhaite
continuer à me battre dans les années
qui viennent et des compétences
économiques de la région notamment
pendant quatre ans facteur important
pour le torse allongé sur les téléports
compétence économique naturellement mais
complètement ceci vis-à-vis des jeunes
des jeunes qui ont souffert on a
découvert une forme de carreman
d'étudiants à l'occasion de cette crise
et aussi des compétences en matière de
mobilité qu'il faut savoir relance et de
développement durable c'est extrêmement
important pour la population qui dans le
cadre de cette crise à changer quelques
habitudes les circuits courts à
l'agriculture tout cela s'est transformé
que nous avons à rebondir à nous
relancer
certes pas qu'elle peut lui il ne faut
surtout pas qu'elle pollue le premier
tour et c'est un petit peu ce que
recherchent d'ailleurs à la fois le
front national et c'est ce que vient
rechercher également la majorité
présidentielle c'est de venir polluer
dans un scrutin local avec un
contournement finalement on saute et on
est déjà avant 2022 et en 2022 on essaie
de se réchauffer d'être dans un match je
veux voir si effectivement on peut pas
creuser à mettre un coin finalement dans
le cadre des régionales pour que les
présidents de droite sortant soit mise à
mal et puis ce dès le départ se dire il
faut fusionner les listes non c'est pas
mon sujet mon sujet c'est de me battre
de respecter les électeurs est d'avoir
un projet cohérent alors proposé pour le
premier tour et je serai en t